se pone en la boca pero este cáñamo no
se fuma si la planta es conocida por sus
flores que producen cannabis pero desde
hace algunas semanas sus fibras también
se utilizan para cuestiones de salud en
francia- una empresa especializada en el
desarrollo sostenible y el fieltro
vegetal ha inventado una mascarilla
hecha a base de cáñamo y es totalmente
biodegradable
el cáñamo tiene propiedades que hacen
que no sea necesario añadir ningún otro
producto ni pegamento ni aglutinante sus
características lo hacen filtra blé y
respirable sin ningún producto añadido
validado por la dirección general de las
fuerzas armadas que indica un
rendimiento de filtración del 89 por
ciento esta mascarilla puede utilizarse
posteriormente para el compost o
directamente para una maceta fue durante
la primavera que la startup youssoufou
tuvo la revelación la mascarilla además
de ser ecológica ayuda en la generación
del empleo local
por la forma que se comporta nuestra
máscara ha despertado mucho interés en
las empresas pero también en las
autoridades locales
somos la única mascarilla biodegradable
hoy en día en francia y europa así que
tenemos clientes en bélgica suiza en
particular en italia
hasta ahora la máscara se ha vendido en
14 millones de unidades a 65 centavos de
euro cada una y se espera que el éxito
no se desvanezca ya que la demanda por
este tipo de productos nunca ha sido tan
alta